Podcast, Podcast, Podcast, Ufo will, will, Florentin will, will, will, will, Florentin will, will, will, Florentin will, will, will, Florentin will, will, will, Florentin will, ich will, Florentin will, und ja auch Steffen Tietze.
Ja, ja, Steffen Tietze, genau, jo, Podcast UFO, yay! Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro von Jonas, Jonas, Jonas, Intro von Jonas, Jonas, Intro von Jonas, Jonas, Anfang, jetzt geht der Podcast, Podcast, Podcast, bitte immer kurz, kurz, kurz, 20 Sekunden, unten, unten, bitte lieber weniger, weniger, unten unten schicken auch zehn, zehn, zehn, mach doch auch ein Intro, Zentrale, Zentrale, at podcast-ufo.fail. Herzlich willkommen meine Damen und Herren, schön dass ihr mit dabei seid bei dieser neuen, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche, manche und sowas dass das liegt uns nicht schickt uns die einst du siehst die wege ich sehe die wäfer und denke nein nein schöner satz ich sehe eure wave ich sehe eure waveform ich denke sie
wie du wirklich bist ich sehe eure waveform und merkt schon da gibt es ne menge denn jedes m hinterlässt ganz besondere Wolke. Ich sehe deine Waveform, ist zu lang schick doch eine kürzere Version ich sehe deine waveform und merke es passt sie nicht ich liebe dich doch Doch du bist nichts für mich.
Oder so.
Ja, es gibt ja bestimmt auch Leute, die wirklich beim Podcast nur die Waveform sich angucken.
Die schauen sich die Waveform an und sagen, ah, die nicht, die skippe ich mal.
Das ist die Blindenschrift, die macht keiner so drüber und dann merken sie, kennen sie alles.
Ja, ich meine, es gibt so viele Medien heutzutage, so viele Podcasts, die man hören kann, Lieder, die man hören kann, Bücher, die man lesen kann.
Da muss man ja auch oft einfach mal sagen, Podcast, ah, zu laut, der Mittel heißt mir zu laut, raus.
Was sich gar nicht durchgesetzt hat, was so ein paar Zeitungsoutlets mal gemacht haben, war dieses Breaking News. Menschen können 90% schneller lesen, wenn man die Augen nicht bewegen muss, sondern man guckt auf ein Ort und dann hast du da die ganzen Wörter, die aufflammen.
Ja.
Und man muss sich das mal gucken. Das ist so geil eigentlich. Man guckt dann auf einen Ort und dann kommt da ganz schnell alle Wörter nacheinander.
Ja. Und man checkt den Inhalt besser und viel, viel schneller.
Aber viel anstrengender.
Nee, finde ich nicht.
Du bist halt, also ich habe mir da wirklich die Kontaktlinse rausgebrannt. Ich war da wirklich so, weil ich habe natürlich dann, also nur um das kurze Erklärung, das ist ein System, wo du dann auch die Geschwindigkeit hochstellen kannst, wie viele Wörter pro Sekunde angezeigt werden und ich war natürlich der Highscore-Jäger, der gesagt hat, zeig mir irgendwie 100 pro Sekunde an und du bist einfach in so einem Wortsug drin und hast einfach Charles Dickens, Moby Dick einfach in 14 Sekunden gelesen. krass natürlich die natur interagiert mit den menschen natürlich auf eine art dass nicht immer beide zusammenkommen können ist okay jetzt 1948 80 man da war es jetzt verrannt aber stell dir mal vor du hast ja weil viele informationen zu bekommen und in unser Gehirn reingepresst zu bekommen, ist ja auch ein Energieaufwand. Stell dir vor, den leistest du dann genauso schnell. Und dann liest du in einer Minute dreissig liest du, ähm, George Orwell. Also du meinst, das ist auch eine Abnehmen-Methode. Weil man sagt ja das, das ist ja immer das Ding, man sagt ja, die meisten Kalorien verbrennt das Gehirn. Und dann denke ich mir, setz doch an.
Warum stelle ich mich auf diese Rüttelmaschinen, warum habe ich diese Schwitzbänder um? Wenn das Gehirn am meisten Energie verbrennt, warum sitze ich nicht in der fucking Uni? Was ist denn dann mit Denksport? Also warum kann man dann sich nicht schön die Pfunde wegdenken? Einfach wenn du immer dreimal, dreimal, dreimal, drei und einfach ganz oft immer mal dreimal, dreimal, drei und das machst du zweimal am Tag und dann bist du Bikinifigur wieder perfekt für den Sommer. Drei, sechs, neun, zwölf, fünfzehn, achtzehn, einundzwanzig, vierundzwanzig, siebenundzwanzig, dreissig, dreienunddreissig, sechsunddreissig, neununddreissig, immer mal drei, aber ich will lieber sterben. Guck mal, das ist genauso wie echter Sport. Sobald man realisiert, ach das muss ich jeden Tag machen, nee dann nicht. Nee, dann würde ich mir lieber die Kugel geben. Nee, dann würde ich mich lieber unter den Rasenmäher legen, dann mach das doch so einfach. Dann würde ich mich lieber in so einen Kärcher, vor so ein Kärchergerät stellen und mir meine Augen wegspringen mit diesem Hochdruckreruckreiniger. Da würde ich mich lieber in eine Kettensäge fassen. Da würde ich lieber in so einen, ich bin noch bei Gartengeräten, da würde ich lieber in diesen Schredderer meine beiden Hände reinstecken. Ich würde mich lieber essen lassen. Ich würde mich einfach in so eine Grube Krokodile werfen und mich einfach zerreissen lassen. Oder noch Tiere, wo es noch länger dauert. Ja, so Störche oder so, die dann wirklich so rauspicken und sowas. Sind Tauben doof geworden? Das ist meine Frage. Aber haben abgebaut. Ich behaupte, ich behaupte wirklich, ich beobachte etwas im letzten Jahr. Ich spreche nicht von in den letzten zehn Jahren oder irgendwie ein grosser, unbeobachtbarer Zeitraum. Ich rede wirklich von den letzten acht Monaten, sechs Monaten sind Tauben bescheuert geworden. Ich behaupte, ich glaube, ich habe eine Taube überfahren neulich. Oh, wie hast du das denn geschafft? Das ist ja eigentlich so leicht, oder? Nein, ich vor allem, ich bin auch noch so ein idiotischer B auch noch für Tauben, wenn die auf der Strasse stehen, obwohl es saugefährlich ist. Und der hinter, weil niemand hinter dir sieht ja, dass du für eine Taube bremst, für die bremst du einfach aus dem Nichts. Ja, du hast aber auch den Stoßstangensticker, wo steht, ich bremse für Tauben. Ich bremse für Tauben. Was die Tauben natürlich auch sehen und dann sagen, ach so, hier, was soll ich da wegfliegen, was, da bleibe ich hier. Da bleibe ich hier, da bleibe ich hier, da bleibe ich hier, oder bleibe ich hier, echt geweiss, wo es allein ist. Aber ja, ist natürlich eine Gefahr. E-Fahrstuhle kriegt man ja eigentlich beigebracht, wenn was auf der Fahrbahn ist, draufhalten, töten. Gas geben. Möglichst grausam unter den Leder, auf den Gummimil, den Mühlen, den Gummirädern zermalmen. War zumindest die richtige Antwort bei der Theorieprüfung bei mir. Ja, ich fand die, die war komisch auch formuliert, aber ich kenne es auch, draufhalten auf den Kopf, also auf die sterblichen Zonen. Todesstoss, einfach direkt, je schneller das Re stirbt, desto humaner, ja, also wirklich ansetzen zum Todesstoss und auch wenn man dafür leicht von der Spur abkommen muss, lieber ist das Re wirklich hinüber, als dass es dann irgendwie noch halbtot sich auf die andere Spur robbt und dann vielleicht eine Gefahr da. Genau, Anfahrmündigkeit D, der schnelle Tod, Ausrufezeichen, der schnell tot. Der schnelle Tod. Haben Sie eine Armbrust zur Hand im Handschuhfach? Ja, gerne. Gerne, das soll noch dreimal draufzimmern. So, repetier Armbrust. Aber woran machst du das fest? Also Tauben, ich würde mal sagen, also natürlich ist die Ernährung schlechter geworden, weil Tauben sind natürlich das Abbild unserer eigenen Ernährung, weil Tauben essen ja das, was wir essen. Schön in der Fussgernzone, fällt eine Pommes runter, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, viel Salz, viel Fett, viel Kohlenhydrate, was bleibt da? Ja, genau, also das gebe ich dir schon recht. Ich glaube, aber die Ernährung kann sich nicht so schnell geändert haben. Ich behaupte, die werden vergiftet oder so lethargisch gemacht. Okay. Dass irgendwie mit den Flugzeugen über uns oder so irgendwie was runterrieselt, was die, keine Ahnung. Tauben direkt treffen sollen. Genau, weil ich beobachte tatsächlich, dass die nicht mehr wegfliegen. Tauben sind lethargisch und dumm oder dreist. Ja, frech. Naja, weil die fliegen nicht mehr weg. Und beim Fahrradfahren ist es so insane, weil die auf dem Fahrradweg landen. Und ich kenne das, weil ich fahre wirklich oft durch den Tauben-Hotspot. Hierhin auch zum Beispiel. Und wenn man auf dem Fahrradweg fährt, die fliegen immer weg. Die sehen das Fahrrad kommen und fliegen aufgeregt weg. So kennt man sie. Das ist der Deal, den wir mit Tauben haben. Genau, ihr dürft unsere Reste essen, dafür fliegt aus dem Weg, wenn wir kommen. Ihr dürft unsere Reste und unsere Wege benutzen. Wenn ihr uns seht, macht euch aus dem Staub. Und dieses heilige Versprechen wurde jahrzehnte und jahrhundertelang geehrt. Genau, da gab es die Treffen. Scholz fährt ins Land der Tauben, Taubenreich, Taubenheim, und dann werden sich die Hände geschüttelt und Flügel geschüttelt, viele Kameras. Köpfe genickt, Scholz natürlich auch der Kultur der Tauben angepasst, nickt mit den Köpfen, Respektsgeste. Genau, da gibt es diesen Ritus, den er danach gemacht hat, da war vorher eben sozusagen so ein Mais verstreut auf dem Tisch und er musste die Hände hinter den Tisch nehmen und wie Tauben musste picken. Und als besondere Ehre durfte Olaf Scholz auch die jungen Tauben aus dem Nest rausschubsen, was eine ganz besondere Ehre ist. Das war dann zum 100. Jahrestag der Tauben-Menschfreundschaft, da musste er das machen, genau. Und vergessen auch das Ei, das Golden Ei, was die Bundesrepublik Deutschland geschenkt bekommen hat im Jahre 1960er oder so.
Ja genau, dieses Golden Ei, was heute nicht geschlüpft ist.
Verrückt, ne?
Das liegt immer noch im Deutschen Staatsarchiv
und wartet da.
Da gibt es diesen Deal, der besagt,
es ist sehr kurz.
Wenn man sich diese ganzen Ritus anguckt,
ist es ein kurzes Abkommen.
Dafür, dass da viele staatsrechtliche Anwälte daran gearbeitet haben, ist das tatsächlich ganz knackig. Super kurz und knackig, da steht einfach nur drin, wir fliegen weg. Macht euch kein No Biggie, wir fliegen weg. Turns out, machen sie nicht mehr. Ja, der Vertrag wurde gebraucht. Es ist so krass, es fällt mir tatsächlich auf. Die sind total lethargisch und dusselig und du willst jetzt hier auf diesem Weg langfahren? Oh, okay, ich gucke kurz in alle Richtungen, um dann langsam abzuwägen, in welche ich denn fliehen möchte. Und das ist so krass. Ich bin teilweise wirklich, weil man ist ja auch gewohnt, dass sie fliegen. Genau, man hat sich damit abgefunden, man fährt einfach darauf zu, man will gar nicht langsamer werden, weil das ist ja oft so ein Ding, wenn du langsamer wirst, ist es so ein was, wer, wie, was, wo, dann entsteht ein Problem, aber wenn du einfach volle Geschwindigkeit weiterfährst, weiß jemand, okay, der bremst nicht, ich flieg weg, alles gut.
Wie die Fahrstuhlfrage, wer bremst?
A, der Stärkere, B, der Schwächere.
C, ich.
Und das ist natürlich immer das Ding, wenn du an der Strasse stehst und es kommt ein Auto,
dann muss das entweder vollständig stehen oder ganz schnell vorbeifahren, damit du weisst, der hält nicht für mich, dann fährt er ganz schnell vorbei, aber wenn der anfängt langsamer zu werden, unklar, dann entstehen Gefahrensituationen, weil du gehst los und so ist es mit den Tauben auch, du musst volle Geschwindigkeit durchfahren. Jetzt aber pass auf.
Da habe ich, glaube ich, eine mitgenommen.
Mit dem Fahrrad?
Einfach übers Genick einfach drüber gefahren.
Da war Auto.
Ui.
Das war so schlimm.
Ich bin dann wirklich langsamer geworden.
War vielleicht auch mein Fehler.
Ja, war dein Fehler.
Aber so, da waren Tauben auf der Strasse.
Und ich kenne das nur so, selbst wenn man mit dem Auto, da sind die eigentlich dann schon relativ schnell mal dann weg.
Wo sind Tauben nachts, fände ich gerade eigentlich auf. Naja, das gehört jetzt auch jetzt hier nicht hin. Sorry. Und dann fährt man darauf zu und die fliegen weg. Und sie flogen nicht weg, dann bin ich langsamer geworden, hab gebremst, langsamer geworden und bin so langsam gefahren, dass sie genug Zeit hatten zu gehen von der Strasse. Ja, ja. Und dann merke ich nur so einen Pff. Dann habe ich so einen Bump gehabtump gehabt. Super super schlimm, super super schlimm. Ja, vor allem die sind ja mittlerweile, habe ich das Gefühl für die Tauben so krass, dass man ja den Moment des Wegfliegens gar nicht mehr sieht, sondern die verschwinden aus deiner Blickfläche und du denkst, die fliegen jetzt gleich los, weil die fliegen im letzten Moment, weil die sagen sich, oh geil, da ist noch irgendwie ein angeschimmeltes, altes Pommesstück, Alter, da muss ich jetzt den letzten Pick kriegen und dann weg. Aber jetzt pass auf, wer hat ein Interesse daran, dass Tauben untergehen? Und jetzt sage ich dir die Antwort. Firmen, die selbstfahrende Autos herstellen. Ich habe einen Bericht gesehen über selbstfahrende Autos und ein riesiges Problem für selbstfahrende Autos, die über diese Kameras haben, die sich drehen und die ständig abwägen müssen, ist sich und nicht. Und ein riesiges Problem, sind Tauben.
Nein. für selbstfahrende Autos, die ja über diese Kameras haben, die sich drehen und die ständig abwägen müssen, und ein riesiges Problem sind Tauben. Weil damit kommen diese Computer überhaupt nicht klar. Aber das macht ja genau Sinn, weil die kommen ja jetzt erst. Richtig, die kommen jetzt erst. Und deswegen kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass irgendjemand Taubengift versprüht oder die irgendwie durch irgendein Coaching oder so lethargischer macht oder so und deswegen die langsam alle überfahren werden sollen, weil die diese ganzen selbstfahrenden autos nicht auf den markt bringen solange die immer wenn eine taube kommt nach links ausscheren und vier leute umfahren deswegen müssen die das irgendwie klären also ich einfach im im code einfach menschen grösser als tauben reinschreiben ja das haben wir versucht weil warum warum scheren aus für eine Taube, um dann in die Familie mit den drei Kinderwägen reinzufahren? Ja, das Problem ist, manchmal verwechselt, verwechselt der Computer Tauben und Menschen. Also das ist immer so ein Ding. Es gibt auch ein so lustiges Video, wo so ein Tesla macht so einen Bremstest und dann fährt er wirklich mit voller Geschwindigkeit auf so eine Kinderpuppe zu und der bremst null, also der bremst gar nicht. So ein Batz fährt diese Kinderpuppe an.
Und drückwärts nochmal drüber.
Schrecklicher Anblick, aber selbst in dem Video, die Ingenieure, die das überwachen, selbst die lachen, weil das einfach so absurd aussieht, wie jemand so volle Geschwindigkeit in voller Beschleunigung, bap einfach, und es sieht so brutal aus, schau ich das gerne mal an, es ist wirklich sehr, sehr lustig und zeigt, dass natürlich noch viel zu tun ist mit selbstfahrenden Autos, aber wenn erst mal die Tauben weg müssen. Das ist ja die Erklärung, ich glaube das wirklich, weil die stören ja wenig Leute, also ich glaube eine Stadt hat auch Interesse daran, weniger Tauben zu haben, weil auch zu wenig, weil wir halt auch wahnsinnig viel Dreck machen. Und zum Beispiel hier auf dem Fahrradweg hierher ins Studio, ich komme an so ein paar Brücken vorbei, die jeden Tag gereinigt werden müssen, weil da drunten immer einfach ein riesen Taubenschiss ist. So eine riesen, würfützenweise Taubenscheisse, weil die immer oben in diesen Bahnbrücken hängen. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass auch eine Stadt sagt, wir wollen uns die Reinegungskosten sparen, wir killen die Tauben. Das heißt, du glaubst, es gibt einen Deal hinter den Kulissen zwischen Tesla oder anderen selbstfahrenden Autofirmen. Und der Stadt Köln zum Beispiel. Und der Stadt Köln, so dass man sagt, das Grundwasser wird jetzt vergiftet. Ja, wir teilen uns die Kosten. Oder es gibt einmal so einen Undercover-Agent, der so eine Pommes-Tüte hat, mit vergifteten Pommes und dann immer kurz bevor er die zum Mund reicht, hat er so einen kleinen, diesen kleinen Dreizack, oh, da fällt ja gerne mal was runter. Da fällt mal gerne was runter. Oh, oh, und so läuft er durch die Stadt und verteilt die Giftpommes und die Tauben fressen das und werden dann träge und werden überfahren von dir. Du bist der letzte Teil einer langen Kette, einer grossen Verschwörung. Aber ich bin nur instrumentalisiert. Ich bin ein unmündiger Bürger, der nur meinem Bürgerjob nachgeht. Du bist einer der Dominos, der einfach umfällt. Ich fälle einfach um. Du bist nicht der erste Domino, du bist auch nicht der letzte Domino. Du bist einfach irgendwo in der Mitte eingeklemmt zwischen Mächten, die grösste sind als du. Und du kannst nur umfällen. Wenn dein Moment kommt, fällst du einfach um. Auf einem kleinen Nussschälchen bin ich in See gestochen, auf einer kleinen Nussschale mit so einem Zahnstocher fahre ich so durch das grosse Meer und um mich herum möchte, ich kann da nichts machen. Ich werde von rechts nach links, so fühle ich mich auch, bin ich von rechts nach links geschleudert und fahre die Tauben oben rechts und links. Ja, aber du bist Erfüllungsgehilfe eines diabolischen oder wie du gerade sagtest, guten Plans. Also wenn du selber willst, dass die Tauben, aber baut man nicht gegen Tauben diese ganzen Stacheln, diese Stacheln über auf Dächer oder so, dass alles so richtig so goth-mässig so cool aussieht, so wie Pinhead, Erasurehead oder so, dass alles diesen Nieten-Look hat, dass alles so wie eine Stadt kommt in die Pubertät und hat jetzt so einen Nietengürtel und überall sind die Stacheln und so. Und ich denke mir so, überall ist Rockmusik, weil es die Tiere verscheucht. Ey, Köln, du bist richtig cool geworden. Aber es ist alles nur gegen Tauben. Ja, also kann gut sein. Auf dem Dom habe ich auch noch nicht so viele Tiere gesehen, wahrscheinlich weil der so stachelig ist, so verziert ist. Es gibt ja immer wieder Pläne, Tiere zu bekämpfen. Du hast es ja mit dem Marienkäferchen erzählt oder ich habe mich letztens an eine Szene erinnert, weil als wir in New York waren, bin ich auch mal so entlang gelaufen. Und die Strasse entlang gelaufen. Und dann ist mir so ein Schulmädchen entgegengelaufen, grosser Rucksack. Das sind keine Tiere. Rucksack, so gross wie das Mädchen selber, riesengross und das Mädchen läuft so vor sich hin und guckt plötzlich ganz ernst und stapft mit voller Kraft auf dem Boden und guckt dann zufrieden und geht weiter. Ich dachte mir, was ist hier gerade passiert? Und ich gucke hin und die hat einen Käfer zerstampft. Und ich dachte mir, okay, entweder ist das eine psychopathische Insektenmörderin
oder denen wurde gesagt,
wenn ihr diese Art von Insekten seht, stampft
die tot. Und du natürlich hier mit deiner Lupe?
Käfer-Sammler Florentin direkt mit deiner Lupe?
Was haben wir hier zu tun?
Tatort. Chitin ist noch warm.
Sie treffen auf Florent, auf Pilz-Sammler,
äh, Käfer-Sammler Florentin.
Der Käfer-Detektiv.
Hey, Moment mal, wo sind die Scherenhände?
Ich will bei Pokémon, aber
naja.
Oh, sorry.
Käfersammler Florentin möchte kämpfen,
er hat null Pokémon, er hat ein
totes Pokémon.
Okay, ich fordere ihn trotzdem heraus.
Flucht, Flucht.
Wurmlio.
Zerstampft am Boden. Zerstampft von Schulmädchen Luisa. Käfersammler Florentin Feld in Oma. Hier, Taubi. Taubsen? Taubson? Taubi. Wie heißt er noch? Taubsi. Ach. Ja, aber da kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass diesem Kind in der Schule eindoktriniert, eingepfeffert wurde, töte alle Käfer auf Sicht und vielleicht kommt so eine Propagandakampagne auch auf uns zu, wenn wir sagen, töte alle Tauben, weil dann ist glaube ich wirklich, dann sind die Tore der Hölle offen. Ich find's super spannend. Also ich beobachte wirklich das hier bis in den Tagen. Habt ihr das auch beobachtet, schreibt's in die drunter Kommentare, drunter Kommentare.
Schreibt's in die drunter Kommentare. Schreibt's in die Drunter-Kommentare. Schreibt's in die Drunter-Kommentare. Schreibt's in die Drunter-Kommentare. Ich glaube wirklich. Du meinst, das ist so ein österreichisches Ding, dass man Drunter-Kommentare sagt und in Deutschland nur Kommentare. Schreibt's in die Drunter-Kommentare, bitte. Schreibt's Renner, lese mal das nächste Woche vor. Ja, vor. Nee, aber ich muss wirklich, das würde ich gerne mal wissen, ob ihr das auch beobachtet oder ob es in meinem Kopf ist. Und ich wittere ja inzwischen Verschwörungen hinter jedem Taubenschlag. Du suchst einfach nur eine Erklärung, dass du ein schäbiger Taubenmörder bist und versuchst jetzt einfach irgendwie dich zu entlassen. Aber was hätte ich machen sollen? Es war ein Geständnis. Was hätte ich machen sollen? Was hätte ich machen sollen? Du sagst, du bremst auch für Tauben. Ich bremse auch für Tauben, habe ich auch gebremst. Wenn sie dann nicht weggeht, ich sehe sie ja nicht mehr. Ich bin gewohnt, auch wenn sie nicht mehr im Sichtfeld ist, wenn man langsam fährt, sie sind schon weg. They made it. Das ist das Abkommen, das ist der Deal. Und dann plötzlich erst mal diesen Bump und man merkt, oh Gott, die war auch nicht verletzt vorher oder so, die war super mobil und ist da rumgelaufen. Das macht es schlechter, das macht es ein bisschen schlimmer. Die war noch jung, so ein ganz junges Hauch. Noch voller Elan und voller Möglichkeit. Voller Lebensfreude. Die hatte noch alles vor sich. Die hat das Funkeln in den Augen. Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum die nicht weggelaufen ist. Die hatte noch viele Pommespackungen vor sich, die sie einfach vom Boden wegschnappen. Na, widerlich. Vielleicht braucht man einfach auch so eine Hupe, das dann so ein für uns Menschen nicht hörbares Geräusch macht oder so, nur für Tauben, Taubenhupe, so ein Was für uns nur so ganz wenig klingt, aber für Tauben ohrenbetaubend laut ist. Betäubend. Oben, Ohrenbetaubend. Obenbetaubend, ja. Ja, ich finde es spannend, sagt mal gerne mal eure Meinung. Schreibt mal gerne eure Nachrichten oder schickt mal uns eine Sprachnachricht und Wir sagen euch an der Waveform entscheide ich schon, hören wir uns die über das andere nicht. Haha, jemand schickt eine jemand schickt eine Nachricht und guu, guu, haha, ja, als ob eine Taube eine Sprachnachricht geschickt hätte, Insider, hier, ich habe einen Whistleblower, guu, guu, guu. Kann man mit Waveformen schreiben? Schreiben oder so coole Formen machen, Herzformen? Manche Buchstaben vielleicht, so ein U ginge, vielleicht alles was so. Wäre mal geil, Heiratsantrag in so einer Waveform oder so. Okay, und dann sagst du, Schatz, ich habe dir was aufgenommen. Satan, Satan, Satan, Satan. Und dann, nee, du musst die Waveform anschauen. Du musst rückwärts hören. So, Schatz, ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden, was du mir gemacht hast. Nee, weil die Waveform, es ist wie Leute, die an Himmel Marry Me schreiben, es ist wie, wenn du die Waveform
anguckst, steht da Marry Me.
Also,
aber niemand guckt sich die Waveform
vom Podcast, ja,
und deswegen habe ich auch Zweifel gehabt und überhaupt
so lange gebraucht für diesen Antrag, weil
du halt so pedantisch immer
ist es egal,
ist es egal. Ich habe Wizard of Oz gesehen
am Wochenende. Du hast Wizard of Oz gesehen?
Ich habe Wizard of Oz gesehen, wir haben ja Wicked gesehen, das H.B. Baxter Musical in New York und da ging es ja um die Geschichte von Wizard of Oz, Glinda und die andere Tabitha. Ja, es ist jetzt auch nicht so schlimm, wenn du die Namen nicht zusammenbekommst. Dass du dann immer einbrichst und dann ist es so eine quälende Stille. Ist auch nicht so schlimm, du weißt nicht mehr, wie die heißen, deswegen kein Problem. Und da gibt es auch eine Szene, und Wizard of Oz ist ein abgefahrter Film, also wirklich, vergesst es. Der gibt von vorne bis hinten überhaupt keinen Sinn. Die Moral ist nahezu unextrahierbar, absolut unmöglich. Also da bin ich gespannt.
Sei keine Frugelscheuchen, Mann.
Ja, es ist ganz, ganz merkwürdig auf jeden Fall. Vor allem, kleiner Spoiler, am Ende ist natürlich die Punchline, ah, vielleicht hat Dorothy alles nur geträumt. Und das ist ja immer so ein narrativer Kniff, wo man denkt, also hat alles, was jetzt hier passiert ist, muss der Logik eines kleinen Mädchens entsprechen, die träumt. Und alles, was jetzt hier passiert ist, hat sie sich ausgedacht und ist sozusagen auf ihren Charakter zurückführbar. Also dann ist es nochmal schwer, das alles zu erklären.
Es ist am Ende so ein bisschen also mehr Schein
als sein, ist die Geschichte von Wizard
of Oz. Am Ende der Wizard of Oz ist ja auch nur so ein
Typ, der Hebel hat und keinen wirklichen
Zauberer ist und dann, keine
Ahnung, die Vogelscheuche
wünscht sich immer ein Gehirn.
Die wünscht sich, dass sie immer ein Gehirn hat, weil sie kann nicht denken
und sie hätte so gerne ein Gehirn. Und der Wizard of Oz gibt ihr dann einfach so ein Diplom und sagt, jetzt hast du ein Diplom, jetzt hast du einen Abschluss. Und die Vogelscheuche so, ah, jetzt bin ich super schlau. Aber der Zuschauer checkt natürlich, das ist jetzt hier nur sozusagen Motivation oder nur irgendwie Schein. Und so geht das bei allen dann, auch der Löwe, der so Angst hat, der kriegt dann Orden verliehen, du bist jetzt ein Held, aber der Zuschauer denkt immer, ah, es geht darum, dass der Schein selbst dazu führt, dass man die Dinge erreichen kann, von denen man nicht dachte, dass man sie erreichen kann. Erreichen sie dann individuell ihre Ziele? Sie erreichen ihre Ziele, sie fühlen sich dann mutig. Das finde ich nämlich schwierig. Es wäre ja geil, wenn er daran scheitert und dann zu merken, ah ne, ein Diplom, sozusagen der Weg ist das Ziel.
Nicht weil du irgendwas bekommst, mach das aus dir noch nichts. Aber das scheint die Botschaft zu sein. Der hat dann so einen grossen Beutel und zieht für jeden einen Gegenstand raus, der Wizard of Oz. Und erst wird ja die Illusion kaputt gemacht vom Wizard of Oz, er ist gar kein Zauberer, er hat nur diese Pyromaschine und diesen Stimmenverstärker, er ist gar kein Zauberer. Das ist den Helden aber völlig egal, sondern er gibt den an und macht sozusagen seinen Trick, mehr Performance als sein, überträgt er auf die anderen, gibt denen Dinge und die sind völlig zufrieden. Und dann, zack, Dorothy wacht auf, es war alles nur ein Traum. Das heißt, Dorothy träumt die Moral der Geschichte, dass man nur Dinge faken muss, um sie tatsächlich zu haben. Es ist wirklich völlig absurd.
Und vor allem, dann musst du ja überlegen, okay, wie ist jetzt sie als Charakter gemeint? Also sie als wieviel Jahre altes bis 15 Jahre altes Mädchen, die denkt das vielleicht und dann geht es aus dem Kino und zermalst dir wie nach Tenet den Kopf und denkst dann Moment, aber das war ja Traube eben, Traube eben
eins ist ja von
Dorothy, genau
so jemand denkt dann vielleicht, träumt
dann so, ah, Schein
führt dann zu dem
genau, gewünschten Zweck
und, aber weil sie ist ja
eine 15-jährige Träumerin
heißt, dass ich als Stefan auf Ebene Null aus dem Kino gehe und denke, nee, ich muss für meine Dinge arbeiten, weil mir wird nichts einfach gereicht. What? Es ist super strange, es ist wirklich ganz, ganz merkwürdig, was die Moral davon letzten Endes sein soll. Aber es ist ja wie ein sehr wilder Film. Es ist ein extrem wilder Film. Es ist ja null Dramaturgie da. Du hast einen Haufen Leute, die entdecken diesen Charakter, der gibt denen Dinge und bei allen nacheinander klappt es Ende von Traum. Ciao, ciao. Ja, der Film, also ich rede von einem alten Film, also schaut euch den an, der ist wirklich fantastisch. Weil Wicked fand ja auch eine gute Story. Wicked war abgefahren, aber der Film Wizard of Oz ist super strange. Wann nicht Wicked war Wicked. Der Anfang ist auch nicht schwarz-weiss, sondern so braun-schwarz. Sepia. So, und dann denkt man, ah, okay, ist ein alter Film. Aber nein, sobald sie im Zauberland von Oz ist, gibt's Farben. Und sie kommt an in dieser Zauberwelt und es gibt erst mal ungelogen 20 Minuten farbenprächtige Paradegesänge von den merkwürdigen Kreaturen in dieser Welt, den Munchkins, was halt irgendwie Kinder sind oder so kleine Leute, die dann halt so rumlaufen in Kostümen. Und es ist so, man denkt sich, wo, was ist hier eigentlich los? Wir bringen jetzt Dorothy um. Aber eine besondere Szene gefällt mir besonders gut, und zwar gibt es ja natürlich die böse Hexe, Wicked Witch, die grüne Hexe, und die fliegt dann, die will immer Dorothy umbringen, aber kann das auch nicht so richtig, weil sie hat diese Schuhe. Also die Regeln sind ganz strange. Regeln der Schuhe? Niemand checkt das. Sie hat diese Rubinen-Slipper. Wer? Dorothy. Weil sie tötet ja am Anfang die alte Hexe, Wicked Witch of the West, und die hat diese Schuhe, zieht die an, also ist sie immun. Es ergibt wirklich überhaupt keinen Sinn von Anfang bis Ende. Und dann will die Hexe immer Dorothy fertig machen und dann fliegt sie mit ihrem Besen einmal auch über den Himmel und schreibt in schwarzer Schrift was auf den Himmel. Und Dorothy guckt dann so völlig voller Angst in den Himmel und dann sehen wir als Zuschauer, was die Hexe in den Himmel geschrieben hat und sie hat geschrieben Surr. S-U-R-R. Surr. Und Dorothy so, ha. Und du denkst sie, was? Und Dorothy guckt voller Furcht. Und dann schalten wir noch mal in den Himmel und da steht Surrender Dorothy. Und ich denke mir einfach, also wie, also wie verwirrender kann man das denn bitte inszenieren? Sie schaut in den Himmel und liest Surr und es ist so, nein, nicht Surr. Ah, Surrender Dorothy. Vor allem, man soll ja hier Angst vor der Hexe haben oder die Gefühle von Dorothy mit nachvollziehen, aber der Zuschauer kann nur verwirrt sein an dem Punkt. Es ist auch weird sozusagen, einen Bösewicht bei so einem Work in Progress Ding zu zeigen. Das ist so, als würdest du sozusagen vor einem Jumpscare zeigen, wie sich das Monster versteckt und in deiner Ecke so wartet und dann sagt, das ist genau das. Ja, oder wie der irgendwie gerade sich die Maske aufsetzt oder sich so das Gesicht voller Blut schmiert oder so.
Und dann sagt er, das ist genau das. Oder wie der irgendwie gerade sich die Maske aufsetzt oder sich so das Gesicht voller Blut schmiert oder so. Und dann so im Spiegel noch mal anguckt. So. Toi, toi, toi. Auch die beiden Zwillinge von Shining. Freddy, du schaffst das. Die Zwillinge von Shining so. Toi, toi, toi. Hals und Beinbruch. Ja. Ciao. Süße, wir haben das. Wir schaffen das. Wir haben das. Wir erschrecken sie jetzt. You go girl. You go. No you go girl. No you go girl. No you go girl. No you go girl. So das kleine Mädchen aus The Ring oder so. Ja. So die Haare fertig machen. Ja, erstmal fertig machen. Es ist super strange. Also es ist ein ganz, und es ist verrückt, weil man sieht diese altmodischen Filme und denkt, das ist so ein langweiliges Ding, so super einfache Erzählstrukturen, aber es ist einfach Wahnsinn. Wahnsinn, ja. Es ist einfach Wahnsinn. Es ist nicht. Aber mir gefällt, also weil wir gerade wirklich in einem Zeitalter leben, wo alles super breit gewaschen ist, also schon. Breit gewaschen? Ja, so breit. Schönes Wort, gehen wir näher drauf an. Ja, eine mischung aus weich gespült weich gewaschen und breit und vielen meinungen und genau und so in die breite mainstream ich ist ja schon alles was ja gerade es schon sehr viel einfach lame lame klar gibt es immer so ausnahmen und so aber schon eher und dann finde ich es fast erfrischend so eine super ja edgy alles alles in eine Richtung, super committal. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das damals als edgy aufgefasst wurde oder was da überhaupt los ist, aber es ist so ein merkwürdiger Film. Es klingt unglaublich originell in eine Richtung gearbeitet und alle waren an diesem weirden Prozess irgendwie beteiligt. Es klingt so an einem Strang ziehend Richtung Originalität. Aber ich kann mir nicht erklären, wie damals Leute den Film im Kino gesehen haben und sagten, ah. Das wird ein Kultklassiker. Daraus machen wir Musical. Es ist extrem aufwendig gemacht und wirklich auch richtig gut. Also die ganzen Effekte und so, das sieht einfach mega gut aus und richtig viel Aufwand. Da gibt es so einen Sturm am Anfang und du denkst wirklich, holy shit, hier fliegt gleich alles weg. Weil du denkst dir, die haben ja auch wirklich einfach ein riesiges Sturm, einfach ein Flugzeug ins Studio geholt und einfach mal die Turbine blasen lassen und das sieht wirklich aus, als werden die gleich weggeblasen. Das ist einfach viel zu stark. Ich habe seitdem nie wieder einen Film gesehen, wo so ein starker Sturm dargestellt wird. Und du so wow und dann bin ich dann so fünf Menschen starben bei einem Sturm am Anfang. Ja, absolut. Und wir haben leider die Turbine falsch rum eingestellt und die wurden dann reingesaugt.
In so einen riesen messerscharfen Rotor. Ja, das riecht abgefahren. Wahnsinn, aber das klingt nach einem coolen Film. Ey, schaut euch an, weil ich habe Wicked nur halb verstanden. Ich auch nicht. Und jetzt habe ich so ein paar Anspielungen verstanden, die da drin waren. Akustisch auch nicht verstanden. Ja, weil ich immer gehustet habe. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Haben wir alles aufgeklärt in Folge 209. 19, äh, nee, war, also wirklich hat mir schon gut gefallen, also ich mochte, ähm, aber ja, ich mag die zwei Songs, die ich kenne, ähm, und der Rest war nicht so meins. Aber jetzt verstehe ich es auch, weil Glinder, die gute Prinzessin, kam immer auf so einer, in so einer grossen Kugel, ähm, auf die Bühne, und jetzt check ich auch, warum, weil im Film auch immer so so eine grosse Seifenblase kommt, wenn Glinda kommt und da ist sie dann drin oder so. Ah, okay. Oder so. Also hast du nicht verstanden, ob sie diese Seifenblase in der respektiven Weisen drin war. Die Seifenblase verschwindet und die Glinda erscheint die Prinzessin. Sie verschwindet, die Seifenblase. Vielleicht kümmest du es nur an. Ich weiss nicht, ob die Blase sich in die Prinzessin verwandelt oder ob die Prinzessin in der Blase drin ist. Wenn eins eine Seifenblase auszeichnet, dann dass sie durchsichtig ist. Müsste man nicht Glinda in der Seifenblase sehen? Ist sie denn da drin? Okay, ich habe den Film nicht gesehen. Jesus, sag das doch. Doch, ich habe ihn gesehen und ihr könnt ihn nicht anschauen. Ich habe ihn noch ein paar Tage geliehen.
Also wenn ihr mir schreibt, ich habe ihn noch ein paar Tage geliehen, dann gebe ich euch mein Passwort und dann kann ich es euch noch ein paar Tage zeigen.
Tolle Idee.
Ich mache das immer gerne Filmelein, ich finde das grossartig.
Ich leie auch gerne Filmelein.
Ich mag das gerne, ich gucke es jetzt einmal an und dann ist es auch gut.
Ich bin auch jetzt Fan von Mubi.
Mubi.
Grosser Fan von Mubi. Da gibt es jeden Tag einen neuen Film, der wird cool vorgestellt. Irgendwie sind es tolle Filme, die da sind und so. Ja, und es sind Independent-Filme und Underground. Und Stefan ist der King. Du bist der Beste. Ich bin schon der coolste Typ. Du bist der Beste. Ja, klar. Es ist die Frage, wenn man coole Sachen bewirbt, hebt man sich dann selber auf ein unangenehmes moralisches Podest oder empfiehlt man einfach was, was man mag. Ja, aber da hast du auch die Grösse dann zu sagen, du kannst auch Dinge empfehlen. Ich kann Mubi empfehlen. Ne, schaut doch mal rein, ist genauso teuer wie Netflix, aber halt vielleicht gerade ein bisschen cooler.
Aber es ist ja alles nur, wir gucken ja einfach gerade nur in diesen einen, wir schauen uns dieses eine Bild an von der Zeit, in der wir gerade sind und jetzt gerade dieses eine, diese eine Frame, da ist es gerade so. Aber kann sich alles ändern. Wir sehen vor allem eine Menge Laub gerade. Eine Menge Laub, Herbst, Laub, auch ein bisschen so der grosse Prank der Natur, finde ich, einfach so. Hey guys, übrigens, jetzt erstmal für ein paar Wochen ist jede Strasse rutschig und ihr werdet euch Knochenbrechen, Unfälle bauen, viel Spaß, weil wir legen unsere ganzen Blätter einfach mal so unter uns, so hier einfach, ach hier bin ich, das ist, weißt du, es gibt keinen Mülleimer in der Natur, wo man sagt, okay, da tun wir unser Laub rein, nee, ich stehe hier gerade, auch dann lege ich meinen Müll einfach direkt unter mich. So, diese Bäume nerven. Bäume sind fucking selbstbewusst, wirklich. Ständig auch diese Laubbläser, die überall rumlaufen um sieben Uhr dreißig morgen. Laubbläser sind das Dümmste der Welt. Laubbläser, wo ich mir denke, also sorry, können wir mal kurz alles anhalten und einfach einen leisen Laubbläser erfinden? Muss das immer laut sein? Gibt es ja auch Laubsauger. Und so und jetzt? Weißt du was? Und die verstehe ich. Laubsauger verstehe ich. Aber Blasen macht mehr Spaß als Saugen. Also wenn du die so vor dir her blasen kannst, das macht schon mehr Spaß. Blasen macht mehr Spaß als Saugen. Finde ich nicht. Na klar. Saugen macht Spaß. Stroheim so reinblubbern mehr Spaß als Saugen. Als Trinken? Naja, Trinken, da kriegst du was. Saugen ist Trinken. Aber du würdest nicht blubbern, wenn es keinen Spaß machen würde. Weil der Zweck eines Stroheims ist ja zu saugen, aber du blubberst ja auch, weil es Spaß macht. Wenn du nicht entscheiden würdest, zwischen Blubbern und jemals wieder blubbern oder jemals wieder trinken, würdest du dich natürlich für Trinken entscheiden. Ja, aber Trinken hat ja einen Effekt über Unterhaltung hinaus. Da würde ich sagen, dass Blubbern steht nur für sich. Blasen macht nichts. Die Dinge, aber trotzdem macht man es, weil es Spaß macht. Nur die Existenz heißt nicht, dass es nötig ist. Doch die Existenz einer Sache, die keinen Zweck erfüllt, zeigt, dass man es gerne macht. Okay, aber sagt nicht aus, dass es auch notwendig ist oder sogar noch wichtiger als zum Beispiel Saugen. Ich finde, Saugen ist viel gewinnt immer. Saugen ist besser als Blasen. Und gerade beim Laubbläser denke ich mir, ich verstehe es nicht, man verschiebt das Problem. Aber auch nicht so koordiniert oder so wie so ein Wingardium Leviosa Zauberstab, wo man alles auf einen geordneten, nein, das ist einfach das ist einfach nur ein und alle sind überfordert und bei dem Saugen denke ich mir, okay, ihr saugt alle die Blätter ein, dann landen die in eurem Ghostbusters-artigen Rucksack und dann könnt ihr damit machen, was ihr wollt. Ja, aber was ist mit dem Igel? Ist der Igel denn auch da drin? Ob der jetzt weggeblasen wird und der seine Augen in seiner Inndarm liegt, liegen dann? Der Igel freut sich ja über die Laubhaufen, wo er dann drin wohnen kann. Die Laubhaufen gibt es ja auch so. Wo er sagt, Mensch, baue mir ein Haus. Und dann sitzt der Igel erst mal mit verschränkten Armen da und sagt, so, wo ist mein Haus, Mensch? Und dann irgendwann gibt es einen Laubhaufen und er sagt, na also, na also, da geht doch. Da lässt man sich aber zweimal bitten. Ach Mensch, na da haben wir es doch. Ja, danke. So, jetzt lasst du mich bitte in Ruhe. Jetzt gehe ich in den Westflügel. So, und dann legt er sich in seinen Haufen rein? Ich meine, so ein Igel, der in so einem Laubhaufen liegt. Liegt der ganz unten? Oder hat der so, es ist ja in der Mitte des Laubhaufens. Ich glaube, da, wo es am wärmsten ist. Oder wo er sich so richtig schön reinkuscheln kann. Aber eigentlich sinkt der ja, müsste der nach unten sinken, oder? Das ist ja wie so ein Bällebad, wo du ja letzten Endes immer auf dem Boden sinkst, oder? Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass man beim Bällebad auf dem Boden sinkt. Meinst du nicht? Ich glaube, nee, nee, ich glaube, das ist nicht wie, weil es halt diese grossen Ballmoleküle hat, bleibt man eher oben. Nee, je kleiner die sind,
desto weniger rutscht man weiter. Wellenbad, aber als Bällebad.
Moment, wenn du jetzt
einen Sandkasten hast, da sind die
Teile ganz klein, dann sinkst
du runter. Genau, je grösser die
Teile sind, desto mehr sinkst du ein.
Und deswegen denke ich beim
Laubhaufen. Nee, nicht unbedingt.
Wasser hat ja ganz, ganz kleine Bälle, wenn man so will. Ja, genau. Da sinkt man ein. Ja, aber Wasser, ja, okay. Aber das ist ein anderer Aggregat. Das ist ja, wenn man holt Luft. Okay, gut. Aber Wasser kann man auch saugen. Nee, du hast recht. Aber ich weiß es gar nicht. Also ich stelle mir immer so vor, bei so einem Laubhaufen stelle ich mir wie bei so einer Pyramide vor, wo du immer so diesen Querschnitt hast von der Pyramide, wo dann so diese Gänge drin sind und dann sind ja auch Räume teilweise wirklich auch im vierten, fünften Stock. Das ist ja nicht nur am Boden, sondern du hast ja wirklich die ganze Pyramide wird genutzt. Und so stelle ich mir auch das Zuhause von so einem Igel vor, der dann so seine Gänge hat und dann mitten, mittendrin hat er so einen Raum, wo er dann schön irgendwie einen Schminkraum und dann irgendwie einen Westflügel, ein Schlafzimmer, Hobbyraum, unten im Keller vielleicht Hobbyraum, unten? Ich finde es so lustig, weil von einer Freundin, die Eltern ziehen Igel auf, wenn sie die finden, die mir verletzt sind oder ausgestoßen sind oder sowas, die rufen dann die Igel-Station an und diese Igel-Station hat dann gesagt, ja, keine Ahnung, also wenn die keine Zeit haben, die gerade abzuholen oder so oder gerade voll sind mit der Igel-Klasse für 2023. Wir haben gerade wirklich alles voll und du siehst im Raum einfach Tausende, Tausende
ihn.
Wir verlieren ihn, wir verlieren ihn.
Ich muss los, tut mir leid, da müssen wir nicht selber drum kümmern.
Komm schon, leb verdammt, leb verdammt, du hast so viel Wofür ist nicht zu lebenlost. Und dann so wie was bei einer Igel-Hotline und man legt so mit so einem bleichen Gesicht auf. Das Igel-Telefon. Hast du das süße Igel-Telefonchen angerufen? Stefan, die sagen, sie können uns nicht helfen. Oh Gott, wir sind auf uns so lange gesteckt. Die sagen, die sind Hals über Kopf in Igeln. Die schwimmen in Igeln. Wir müssen ihn selber aufziehen. Aber schwimmt man auf Igeln? Die verhaken sich. Jedenfalls haben die immer Igel am Start. Und ich habe die Theorie aufgestellt, dass die Mutter, das ist ein bisschen eine Edgy-Theorie, aber die Igel verletzt, damit einen Igel aufziehen kann. Weil komischerweise haben sie immer so ein süsses Igelgehege bei sich. Ah, uns ist wieder ein Igel zugelaufen und wir haben ihm wieder einen Igel, wir geben dem wieder einen süßen Namen und die erste Milch. Hatte jemand das Beinchen abgeschnitten, oh nein. Münchhausen, es ist Münchhausen-Syndrom. Und ich glaube, das ist wirklich, es ist ja, man spricht ja oft, gibt es ja weibliche Täter, gibt es Täterinnen, it's not a thing. Bei Münchhausen sind es eher die Frauen. Ich glaube, die Mutter verletzt Igel. Ich sage nicht, dass es stimmt. Okay, ist eine Theorie, ist eine Arbeitstheorie. Ist meine Arbeitstheorie. Die müsst ihr falsifizieren. Was sind das denn für Verletzungen, die diese Igel haben? Sind das Stichwunden, ausgerissene Stacheln, merkwürdige Verbrennungen? Genau. Und dann so, und neulich kam dann raus, ähm, irgendwie, der eine Igel ist, glaube ich, ertrunken, oder sowas, weil sie dem Wasser hingestellt hat, und der letzte ist verdurstet, weil sie ihm dann kein Wasser mehr hingestellt haben. Wie man es macht, ist falsch. Aber am Ende sterben sie alle irgendwie durch menschliches Versagen und ich glaube da nicht mehr dran. Ich glaube, es ist schon auch süss, einen Igel zu haben und es ist auch schon cool, vor den Nachbarn immer als diejenige zu gelten, die wieder einen Igel aufgenommen hat. Hast du gehört? Die Münchhausen haben wieder einen Igel aufgenommen. Was, Brigitte, Münchhausen hat einen neuen Igel? Also deine Theorie ist, sie verletzen die, kümmern sich darum und wenn sie zu eigenständig werden oder zu sehr Gefahr laufen, wieder auf eigene Faust leben zu können, dann... Ups, wo hast du denn ein Beinchen... Ups, jetzt habe ich leider einmal aus Versehen draufgehauen. Ja, da so eine Spritze rein mit so einer Krankheit, irgendwie so Cholera. Ebola. Ich habe noch eine Spritze Ebola in der Schublade. Karl, die Spritze Ebola. Wirklich, wir haben nur noch zwei. Wir haben nur noch zwei, okay. Von wie viel? Und dann ballern die so rein und dann so, oh, er muss doch ein bisschen länger bei uns bleiben. Und der Igel so, oh, mir geht's ganz schlecht gerade. Ich krieg ganz viel Fieber, kein Problem, ich glaub ich muss mich noch mal hinlegen. Und dann aus Igelperspektive kommt so dieses grosse Gesicht und dann so ein Taschentuch und dann macht sie die Schweisstropfen von der Stirn weg und dann das grosse Gesicht, du musst noch ein bisschen bei uns bleiben, gute Besserung, gute Besserung. Ist nur eine Arbeitstheorie. Das ist aktuell eine Theorie, eine unbestätigte Hypothese, die jetzt natürlich wahrscheinlich weiter verfolgt wird von dir. Aber tatsächlich ist, ach so. Nö, sie wird aufgestellt, im Podcast erzählt und dann liegen gelassen. Und dann wird sich nie wieder ein Gedanke mit beschäftigt. machst das Wasser heiss, giest es in die Teetasse mit dem Teebeutel und dann wird der stehen gelassen. Und dann wird sich nie wieder ein Gedanke mit beschäftigt. Du machst das Wasser heiß, giesst es in die Teetasse mit dem Teebeutel und dann wird der stehen gelassen und nach zwei Stunden schüttest du ihn weg. Oder was mir häufig passiert, ich mache den Wasserkocher an und dann ist es vorbei. Ich vergesse, dass ich den angemacht habe. Passiert das auch häufig? Der Wasserkocher so, so, jetzt ist das Wasser fertig. Stefan, wir sind bei 100 Grad angekommen. Stefan, der Kochpunkt wurde erreicht jetzt. Jetzt geht es wieder bergab ab jetzt. Stefan? Stefan? Und aus dem Nebenraum hat man so. Ah, Family Guy. Stefan, hey! Oh, ich liebe Kaffee. Oh nein. Aber ich mache mir so selten Tee, dass es wirklich wahrscheinlich 80 Prozent meiner, ich mache mir jetzt eine Tee-Aktion, landen dabei, dass ich vergesse, dass die Wasserkocher angemacht wird. Arme Wasserkocher. Immer, oh, FWT, dann streng ich mich jetzt an. Los, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß,inigter Tropfstein wegen Köln. Kölner Wasser ist kalkhaltig hoch tausend. Ja? Ja, ist sehr kalkhaltig. Aber ist nicht gefährlich. Ganz im Gegenteil, ist aber gut. Ist aber gut. Bisschen Kalk ist gut? Habt keine Angst vor Kalk. es macht nichts eurem Körper. Es macht gar nichts, es macht wirklich nichts. Hey, und wenn schon, dann ziehe ich euch wieder auf bei mir zu Hause, päppel ich euch auf. Du hast die ganze Stadt in der Kontrolle. Aber Wald gegen Igel ist ein Thema. Wald gegen Igel? Wald gegen Igel, Samstag 20.15 Uhr auf ProSieben, Wald gegen Igel. Haben wir noch irgendwelche Ideen, haben wir noch irgendeine Idee, irgendwas oder senden wir wirklich Wald gegen Igel? Wir senden Wald gegen Igel. Wer gewinnt? Team Wald bestehend aus Axel Stein, Elton und Joko und Team Igel bestehend aus Barbara Schöneberger und Schär. Warum sind sie zu zweit? Weil sie Schär haben. Ah, okay. Das klingt so, als hätten wir alles Geld für Schär ausgegeben und als hätte man vergessen, dass es einfach drei gegen drei fairer ist. Aber warum ist Schär besonders gut in dem Format Wald gegen Igel? Naja, das sehen wir, wenn wir die erste Kategorie sehen. Stachel oder Dorne? Oh mein Gott. Und zwar werden die Kandidatinnen gestochen. Blind gepikst? Und sie müssen sagen, werden sie von einer Dorne, also Wald, oder von einem Stachel, also Igel, gestochen. Mäntiere, genau. Genau, sie müssen gucken, weil sie gestochen werden. Au! Ja, Scher? Boah, keine Ahnung, das ist mega mega. Also es war so dick, wahrscheinlich Igel oder ja. Scher sagt Igel und wir schauen nach. Nein, es war die Dorne, ein Punkt für Team Wald. Au! Joko? Ja, Joko. Ja, keine Ahnung, äh, äh, keine Ahnung, ich glaube, äh, äh, Igel? Und wir schauen mal nach. Und nein, es war die Dorne. Also eins zu eins. Es ist eine Sendung. Was wolltest du denn sagen? Gewalt gegen Igel. Gewalt gegen Igel.
Ist ein Riesenthema.
Ich habe auch mal aus Lokalnachrichten entnommen, der grosse Igelmörder, der Igel in Mülleimer geworfen hat und angezündet hat. Da musste... Ich habe auch mal einen Igel, der lief bei mir rum und ich habe den dann nehmen müssen, von einem Hund gerettet, weggebracht. Und dafür, dass er fucking übersät ist mit Dornen, kann man den sehr leicht nehmen und einfach wegbekommen aber ich glaube dir ist fast aber setzt der igel die dorn auch ein also ist es so ein ich sehe gefahr also jetzt dornen stacheln oder ist es so ein ah der will mir helfen stacheln aus also hat er so hat er so ein schiebregler das war so süß der hat mir aus der hand gefressen ich habe dem kurs zu essen gegeben so ein bisschen Hundefutter. Habe ich vorher gegoogelt, ob es geht. Gespart euch die Kommentare. Aber ich habe den so geführt und der hat mir aus der Hand genommen. Diese kleinen süssen Händchen auch. Und die sind so süss. Die sind wirklich süss. Mit diesen riesigen spitzen Nasen und so kleinen Händchen. Und dann hat er gegessen. Er hat sehr Angst gehabt, aber dann trotzdem auch gerne gegessen, sehr schnell. Schnell und angsterfüllt gegessen. So schmeckt es am besten. Mir steckt Angst und Nervosität immer wahnsinnig auf den Magen. Ey, die Angst ist mit, auf jeden Fall. Beim Igel nicht. Wisst ihr, was ich gerade gegoogelt habe? Mach das gerne mal, Igel ohne Stacheln. Das ist eine gute Googlesuche, das ist wirklich eine gute. Oh mein Gott, eine Ratte, eine Ratte, eine gute. Eine fucking Ratte. Das ist eine gute Ratte. Aber der ist schon niedlich, ne? Der ist schon niedlich. Nee, finde ich ein Null. Igel ohne Stachel. Er sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Hoden. So, jetzt mal ... Also er sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Hoden, muss man sagen. Hoden mit Gesicht, muss man schon sagen. Und jetzt meine Google-Anfrage, mein Google-Tipp. Der Google-Tipp der Woche. Schildkrö der Woche, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,achsen mit dem Panzer, das war nämlich der Gag.
Boah, unschänzlich, ich kotze gleich alles.
Die sind so widerlich, weil die sind so verwachsen mit dem, so eklig, alles was da kommt ist widerlich.
Okay, Achtung, ich habe noch eine Google-Suche, Kamel ohne Höcker.
Super.
Einfach Lama. Ist ein Kamel ohne Höcker einfach ein fucking Lama? Ja, ich glaube schon. Okay, jetzt kommt meine Google-Suche, Giraffe mit kurzem Hals. Gibt's einen? Gibt's bestimmt, oder? Ja. Meine Google-Suche ist Vogel ohne Flügel. Ah, der Kiwi-Vogel. Der Kiwi-Vogel. Süss, der sieht auch aus wie so ein einfach wie so ein Muffin, wie so ein Schokomuffin einfach so ein bisschen. Also manche Tiere sehen schon sehr lecker aus, obwohl es jetzt glaube ich gar nicht so sind. Giraffen, die trinken, weil deren, das ist eigentlich, nee, das ist sehr lustig, weil, googelt mal kurz, ist das eine Mitmachsendung, Giraffe trinken, weil man sieht dann, weil deren, die sind ja so gross, damit die in diesen heissen Orten, wo nichts wächst, oben an die Bäume kommen. Das heisst, alles in deren Körper, die ganze Physiognomie, ist für oben das Essen. Dabei wurde vergessen, dass man auch trinken muss. Ach Scheiße! Nein, weil wir haben jetzt die grössten Hälse der Welt. Oh fuck! Ey, wenn du sie siehst, die sind so hoch. Oh, dumm. Oh, wir sind so dumm.
Oh, wir sind so dumm.
Und ist streng genommen nicht, Kamele würden sagen, Trinken ist wichtiger als Essen.
Okay, ja.
Weil, guck mal, wie sie trinkt, guck mal, wie eine Giraffe trinkt.
Es sieht, es funktioniert nicht.
Ich kann das kaum.
Es sieht aus wie so ein Zelt mit so Stangen, weil es so diagonal ist und dann einfach ein... Und die Gaffel muss sich auch so ein bisschen nach hinten lehnen, damit sie nicht nach vorne umfällt, weil der Hals ja so lang ist. Ey, stell dir das mal vor. Aber wie albern ist das denn von der Natur gelöst? Vor allem wie hoch die schlucken muss. Die muss... Stell dir vor, du schluckst einfach zweieinhalb Meter nach oben. Aber es ist doch leichter, denen irgendwie Krallen zu geben, dass sie die Bäume hochkrabbeln können, um dann da zu essen.
Fuck! Holy shit, wir haben die komplett falsch geplant.
Fuck, das wäre so viel besser gewesen.
Wir haben die so verkackt.
Das ist so dumm.
Wir haben die so verkackt, weißt du das? Shit.
Können wir die zurückziehen?
Können wir nicht mehr.
Können wir einen Austausch machen?
Nee, ich habe schon PDF exportiert.
Der ganze Bauplan ist schon raus hörst du das
bimmeln hier auch ja ist das von draußen was ist das ihr hört das wieder nicht aber wir haben
sehr irritierendes Geräusch hier bei uns in der Villa in unserem Palast, in unserem Prunksaal. Jetzt drehen wir durch. Quatschig. Quatschig, wir sind in einem Quatsch-Mood. Quatschig, aber Giraffen, die trinken, ist schon eine gute Sache. Es ist ja der Naturstrohalm, ne? Es ist eigentlich der Naturstrohalm, weil die müssen, ist es anstrengend, hochzuschlucken? Ey, dass du Saugen überblasend stellst, ist so dumm einfach. Sorry, du wirst dich so ärgern für diese These. In zehn Jahren. In zehn Jahren wirst du auf dein Leben zurückblicken und sagst, ich habe eigentlich alles richtig gemacht. Wenn die Blaspartei gegen die Saugpartei irgendwie die absolute Mehrheit im Bundestag holt, dann werde ich mich umgucken. Ja, oh ja. Dann werde ich umgucken. Aber ich werde denunzieren. Dann muss ich mich für Aussagen entschuldigen. Herr Tietze, haben Sie nicht in Folge 386 des mittlerweile in Vergessenheit geratenen Das-Podcast-Ufo-Podcast-Projekts gesagt, dass Sie Saugen über Blasen stellen? Er ist ein Sauger! Das ist doch ein verlaupter Sauger! Sauger! Raus mit dem Delizonten Sauger! Nee, bla, das ist schon besser. Ich meine, ich meine auch, wenn du so eine kalte Jahreszeit, wenn du so eine heisse Tasse Kaffee oder Tee hast. Ja, eben. Eben. Drüber pustest so. Der Mensch macht es sich aber auch schwer, weil er will... Moment, auch da ist doch der Trinkfaktor der bessere. Nee, das tut weh, es ist viel zu heiß. Aber du wählst doch den Tee. Aber die Vorfolge. Du machst doch nicht zum Pusten den Tee. Ja, aber das ist der Bonus obendrauf. Du machst doch nicht zum Pusten den Tee. Du musst doch Pusten nicht den Tee machen. Du machst den Tee zum Trinken. Es ist ja die zusätzliche Freude des Pustens, was ja als übergeordneter Genussfaktoren. Nein, natürlich geht es um das Trinken. Nein, nein, der Genuss, dafür sind wir Menschen und leben, für den Genussfaktor darüber hinaus. Aber Marcel, es geht doch auch um Trinken. Essen Sie nur Brot, essen Sie nur Brot? Ja, aber heiss nicht, Helmut Karasek. Das ist immer ihr einziges Argument, Helmut. Meine Imitationen sind so schlecht, dass ich immer hier, das beginnt, so war ich mit Exigent Heisse. So war ich Donald J. Trump Heisse. Ich wäre nicht Abe Lincoln, wenn ich nicht... War sehr gross, Abe Lincoln, trotzdem noch den Hut aufgabt. Sehr fisslige Stimme auch. Sehr leise. Leute, sollten wir vielleicht nicht die Sklaverei abschaffen? Ich weiss nicht, wie es dir geht, Frankie, aber ich bin kein Fan von dem Typen. Also vielleicht ist es gar nicht so gut, Leute, als Eigentum zu bezeichnen. Ich finde ja gute Ideen, aber ich nehme sie ihm nicht ab, weil er so winselt. Lasst uns ins Theater gehen, anstatt zu diskutieren. Auch Goethe hätte man wahrscheinlich damals schon irgendwie mehr abgefeiert, wenn er nicht die ganze Zeit so einen Schleim auf der Stimme gehabt hätte. Ja gut, Goethe Zitat. Wer den Apfel nicht ehrt, der Birne nicht wert. Der Birne nicht wert. Die waren einfach nur faul damals, sie haben einfach Birne statt Birne gesagt. Wem der Apfel nichts wert, der Birne nicht ehr. Wer den Apf nicht erd, der Birn nicht wert. Guck mal, da haben wir doch neuen Merch. Also das ist doch mal Merch. Zu Goethe, wer den Apf nicht erd, ist dem Birn nicht wert. Wer den Apf nicht erd, der Birn nicht wert. Wie der Bienen, sozusagen.
Der Birn, ja.
Der gesammelte Bienenschwarm als Intelligenzpunkt.
Als ein neues Wesen, ja.
Aber man könnte natürlich auch den Min, die Gesamtheit der Menschen als einen Organismus betrachten, der ...
Dusseligen Scheiss macht.
Dusseligen Scheiss macht und vielleicht auch krank ist.
Du meinst, ein Virus hat uns befallen.
Ein Virus der Arroganz.
Und er nennt sich Gier.
ja, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, aber du musst halt besser vortragen, ich glaube dir halt niemanden. Ja, gut, ja, gut.
Nee, aber hast schon recht, mag schon recht haben.
Aber ich glaube, deswegen hören Leute nicht das BPO das Podcast UFO.
Ach so, für meine spitzen gesellschaftlichen Analysen, die immer dark, dark, dark sind.
Ja gut, aber wir leben das natürlich auch eine Zeit, wo man das Licht suchen muss, wenn man es will. Und ich finde, es ist jede Woche in dir. Aber sollten wir in die Wimotten ins Licht fliegen oder sollten wir uns nicht der Dunkelheit stellen? Ich würde gerne irgendwas so sehr lieben wie Mottenlicht, die einfach sagen, Alter, fahr dir gerade. Einmal sowas lieben wie Motten wie Mottenlicht. Das ist einfach das Geilste der Welt. Du, ich war letztens an so einer Lampe und das war so geil, wirklich, ich war direkt an der Birne, ich war direkt an der Birne und ich wäre fast wirklich eingesaugt worden von diesem unendlich gleißenden Lichtpunkt. Ich nehme so eine Motten-Schule vor, wo eigentlich nichts beigebracht wird, ausser niemals ins Licht fliegen. Ja, und der Lehrer macht den Overhead-Projektor an und alle ... Ach nein, ich wollte nur die Folie zeigen. Also so gegen den Overhead-Projektor. Ja, ich mache mich aus, ich kann alle wieder einem lieben Platz geben. Gut, dann schreibe ich es an die Tafel. Wir fliegen alle gemeinsam, liebe Klasse, nicht ins Licht, nicht ins Licht, denn dann sterben wir in der Qualvollen Tod. Ja, weiss ich ja nicht, ne? Also, hört die irgendwann auf, die Motte? Also ist es irgendwann, dass sie sagt, so jetzt reicht aber auch, hu, jetzt habe ich mich vorher gefressen, jetzt, boah, das war jetzt eine gute.
Genau, und in der Schule, als Lann schon alle so Klamottenreste.
Ja, jetzt wäre ich auch gut, so eine kleine Dehne.
Oh, was hast du heute, Lisa?
Ah, ich habe wieder nur Cort.
Oh, ich habe nur Jeans.
Was, wirklich, teilst du was?
Nein.
Oh, ich habe nur Cort. Nein, ich hab wieder nur Kort. Oh, ich hab ne Jeans. Was, wirklich, teilst du was? Oh, ich hab nur Kort. Nein, ich mag kein Kort. Was ist das da hinten? Sagt nicht Satan. Ne, eine Taschenlampe. Ach so. Du glaubst. Nein, Entschuldigung, also, nein, es ist schwer, Tieren in den Kopf zu gucken. So, alles was man kann, ist, man kann ihnen Optionen geben und gucken, was sie vorziehen. Du gibst einem Hund Hundefutter und Eis. Wir machen ein Turnier. Wir brauchen eine Motte und hundert Stoffe. Es gibt eine Gruppenphase und es gibt Sechzehntelfinale, Achtelfinale, Viertelfinale, Halbfinale und Finale. Aber gibt es ein Lower Bracket? Also wenn du verlierst, kannst du noch eine Chance haben, nochmal reinzukommen. Kein Lower Bracket. Aber du hast ja immer das Problem, was ist, wenn in der ersten Entscheidung direkt Platz 1 gegen Platz 2 kämpft. Gut, da machen wir ein klassisches Ligasystem, alle gegen alle, wir lassen alle immer gegen alle antreten.
Alle gegen alle, okay.
Und dann Playoffs, und dann noch Playoffs.
Playoffs, okay.
Und dann die ersten acht, eins gegen acht, zwei gegen sieben, drei gegen sechs.
Okay.
Okay?
Ja, also wir haben eine Motte und präsentieren der Motte neutral, zwei Stoff.
Aber jetzt brauchen wir die neutralste Motte.
Es kann ja sein, dass manche Motten eher auf andere Sachen stehen.
Und ehrlich gesagt würde ich sogar eine Hin- und Rückrunde machen, um einmal Stoff A links und einmal Stoff A rechts zu haben, um das Ergebnis zu verifizieren. Du meinst nicht, dass sie, okay, weil wir machen immer Seitenwechsel. Nicht, dass die Motte immer nach links geht. Verstehe, was du meinst. Und deswegen wechselt man es immer durch. Hinspiel, Rückspiel. Dann machen wir, ja, okay. Trotzdem würde ich dann auch noch Halbzeiten machen. Also eigentlich genau wie Fußball. Ja, okay. Nee, finde ich gut. Und dann haben wir am Ende dieses jahrzehntelangen Prozesses den leckersten Stoff gefunden. Genau, für Motten. Und die Motte hat nie geredet. Wir haben einfach nur ihre Entscheidung interpretiert. Ja, jetzt mach's nicht weniger, also die Motte hat nie geredet, als wäre es ein Achievement, eine Zeitersparnis oder sowas. Die Motte musste nie ihre Entscheidung begründen.
Nö, dafür mussten wir ein Riesenturnier jahrzehntelang aufbauen.
Ja, wir haben uns finanziell da auch vielleicht ein bisschen verhoben.
Ja, es hat eben drei Millionen Euro gekostet.
Ja, weil natürlich so eine Motte ...
Wir wollten es neutral.
So neutral, wie es nur eben geht.
Aber am Ende weiss ich nicht, ob es wirklich so neutral war.
Und hätten wir ... Ja, ich weiss.
Weil das Sartar-Stück war ein bisschen grösser als die Seide so und das ist halt auch ein paar führten was ich hab's einparfümierend aber von welchem parfüm bist du ausgegangen dass es motten mögen würden so ein lockt parfum lavendel das sind ja auch die lavendel lock ja lass mal riechen weißt du warum ich es gemacht habe es tut mir so leid ich fühle mich so. Warum hast du es getan? Aber es wurde immer grösser, das Turnier wurde immer grösser und dann irgendwann habe ich im Schwarzmarkt gemerkt, dass Lotto darauf wetten, auf Stoffe wetten. Die Motte? Lotto-Motto? Nein, nicht die Motte, du hast alle, du hast die Kulette falsch verstanden. Nein, die ganzen Menschen, die so ein Turnier gesehen haben. ja die haben auch das er Ergebnis der Stoff. Und dann habe ich irgendwann gedacht, weil wir uns so in den Ruinen manövriert haben, mit diesem Riesenstadien, die wir gebaut haben. Wir wollten es so neutral machen wie möglich. Und dann habe ich gedacht, komm, ich sprühe es ein und dann lasse ich Satan gewinnen ... Du hast selber auf Satan gesetzt. Ich habe selber auf Satan gesetzt.
Stefan, wir wollten nie so werden.
Du hast die Neutralität geopfert.
Das war unser wichtigstes Projekt.
Wir beiden stehen für Neutralität.
Jetzt ist alles ruiniert.
Wir können alle die ganzen Vorrunden, die Rückrunden, die Relegationen, Derby, können wir jetzt alles über Bord schmeissen, weil wir nicht wissen, wer eingegriffen hat wo. Das ist alles ruiniert. Ich habe übereignet. Du hast in jede Begegnung eingegriffen? Jede Begegnung eingegriffen. Immer mit dem gleichen Lockstoff. Lavendel. Und die Motte hat immer auf Lockstoff angesprungen. In gewisser Weise haben wir also doch etwas herausgefunden, nämlich dass Lavendel über allem steht. Über jedem Stoff. Vielleicht mögen Motten Stoff auch gar nicht so. Nee, es ist nur das zweitbeste. Ach Lavendel. Ja gut, das war jetzt natürlich ein finanzieller Aufwand, aber wir werden uns davon erholen. Jetzt das Ganze mit Marienkäfern und allen Pflanzen. Ja gut, jetzt ist unsere Glaubwürdigkeit kaputt. Wir müssen uns entweder unter anderem Namen machen oder irgendwie eine internationale Aufsichtsbehörde engagieren. Okay, dann lasst uns die Aufsichtsbehörde engagieren. Wir lassen es euch wissen. Ihr habt natürlich die grossen TV-Pakete bezahlt, die Abos laufen. Ihr wollt natürlich auch sehen, wie sich das alles entwickelt. Das könnt ihr, wir entschuldigen uns und versuchen bis nächste Woche ein Statement vorzubereiten.
Ja, wir bessern uns, sorry, sorry, sorry, ich wünsche euch alles Gute.
Dickes Motten, sorry.
Kommt gut durch die Woche. Ja, kommt bitte.
Aber Leute, macht langsam, arbeitet von
einem Tag zum anderen, nicht schon irgendwie
vorausplanen. Nein, nein, nein, nicht am Montag, schon
am Donnerstag. Nein, das ist albern, das ist albern
und ihr stolpert über den Dienstag.
Absolut. Macht's gut, haut rein,
währenddessen wir steigen ein und heben ab und sind weg.
Wir sind komplett weg. Ciao, ciao!